happiness is [ __ ] you think Picasso
was happy think Hemingway was no art
worth the dam was ever created out of
happiness I can tell you that much
that's where we're all such miserable
[ __ ] so you know you're a miserable
[ __ ]
do you think I'm an idiot of course I
know there's only one place left in the
world that processes Kodachrome and
that's Duane's photo in persons Kansas
your father found four rolls he shot a
really long time ago and he wants you to
drive them I've not spoken to the man in
over a decade he's dying
let's go we're burning daylight what
you're going to huh unless you want to
give me my shot he's one of the world's
greatest living photographers remember
every shot I've ever taken
you remember all yep when's my birthday
for every 19 February 19th man should
know his father no matter what kind of
bastard he is merge onto i-80 West I
mean that thing for secondly the hell
are you doing we're taking the scenic
route
this was your room yeah you can tell a
lot about someone's past from the music
they listen to can I say I was a moody
kid that's not how I see it
kid myself that I was any kind of
husband or father
yeah you have a great big life
[Music]
having that comes from that in the past
given up on swatch stuff in my life
I'm tired oh geez take pictures to stop
time to make moments to maternity why'd
you come on this trip let's see how you
measure up against the colossal bastard
I've hated all these years how am i
doing you're on your own
I remember better day
[Music]
you